Đại vội mùi bún của đàng diễn xà và thêm đất nước mức và gia đảng phát triển của tính bức phá,
kính nguyên vương mình của rất tộc.
Sọc bố kẻng nấy, vực trình bị mơ phán kẻ thật sự điều biểu của chỉ thuệ bản đứng tầm yên.
Vừa vương phán từ miên tắc, vừa sạo tính sáng tạo.
Chính đại yếu tối theo chốt mà gặp thành công của đại vội bún,
và điên công đường phát triển của đất nước trong nhiều ngặc tới.
Nhận gió tầm quan trọng ấy, toàn bộ hệ phương chính trị đang khẩn trường,
bài bản từ kẻ quy trình xây dự, bỏ bỏ văn kẻ dự thảo văn kẻ đất bộ bệ bún.
Theo kẻ hoài, các vòan tương cá của tổ biến tập phán kẻ đã ạ chực kết dự đại bộ đả bộ các phân sở,
và trên phân sở, lắm hề kết thù và tổng hợp y tế tập phóc, tức xí bộ đả bộ.
Tại các đả bộ chỉ thuộc trường, kết tục xanh thệ sáng khóa đảm, lệ thảo lật và đảm phóc sâu và dự thảo.
Một mình chính thư biểu với tại đại bộ đả bộ các khu phân đảm giường đình nhất,
phân bộ bế bún sinh bế bún đả bộ trịt quốc, đã thông gợt
đảm bóc ý kiến tâm dưới và có trường sâu vào dự thảo phân kẻ chình đại bộ bún.
Không chỉ bảo gạm lấy đủ hệ số nước ý kiến, mạc phân sạm hơn là chức lựa bóc ý đảm tà.
Dự thảo phân kẻ đả bộ bún của đảm, đã có đăng được kết thù trên tý khẩn trường, khóa học,
phóc câu thịt, mỗi kiến của lớn hay nhỏ, đều được có trọng, mỗi đệ sốt đều được xem sát
phân tích thủ gáo, tự đó hó phân nân cảo chức lựa dự thảo.
Bám sát trị đổ và chức được sận thảo, tổ bị tổ lâm đại nhiều lần làm việc chức phép với tổ
với tập, linh tục lĩnh hướng, đều trình và yêu cầu hành thiện.
Trong cuộc làm việc mới đây, tổ bị thương nhìn mạnh, văn kẻ đại bối mấy bún cử đang
với 2 trực cuộc là báo cáo chiến chi, và trương trình hành động nhập kẻ hành in không trong hệ sấu
hành in không trong bà mốt, phải là lời tâm kết mạnh mẽ của đảng trước nền dân về một sai đoạn phát triển mới.
Dù hối cứ tình thản trình nghiệm càng nhất để nhìn khẩm chi thành viên để hóa khăn kẻ tục lực
của gáo khẩn trường, mọi bạn để hóa khuyện cả quân bản tất cả tình thản của học này.
Hình lâu để hóa khuyện với trở thành bí đốc lực lột mối tư duy hóa hình đậu.
Chúng ta sẽ không trí chỉ, khơi giải thác phỏng phát triển, phát triển để sức mạnh đại gần kết toàn dân tập quan đảng.
Hình thủ được khẩy cơ, người qua phát thức kết đưa đơn nước bất kết phần đường dân dân dầu, nước mạnh dân chủ của mọi mạnh mạnh mạnh mạnh.
Nhi tổng thề công tác trình bệ bán kẻ trái đại hội mề bún đang kết bún dương, mài bàn, khoa học dân chủ và sáng tạo.
Vy tổ chức lấy y kến sông tập tụ cơ sở bị trương hơn, phát lý chỉ tệ tòàn đảng, quan sân, quan quân,
người kết tụ tối đà phải tệ sức thiết thực, cùng với sự chỉ đạo quyết liệt của tổng kết thư và các cộp quan trương hơn.
Tất cả đã tạo thành vụ quy trình sình mực hiện đại dân chủ.
Dự thảo văn kết đảo vụ mề bún, đi tế được đi vọng sẽ hội tụt lấy đủ có trữ tổ, tâm dình chính lợp, dư duy tổ mới, giải phát bất lực phát và tính phát trí cao.
Sinh đáng và kinh trình hâm sẽ trạm đường hát trình mới của đến nước, khó phần vứt tịch thành công của đại gỗ vừa vốn.